8 news now first he tried to burn down a
puppy store now he's accused of trying
to kill someone
eight news now reported on that arson
and animal cruelty case
back in 2014. now our i-team has taken a
look at what has unfolded since then
vanessa murphy has a story and we do
want to warn you
some may find video in this report
disturbing
this is video of kirk bill setting fire
to a puppy shop in 2014.
you can see the animals in their cages
as the flames near
the fire sprinklers kicked in the dogs
were rescued
and kirk bills and store owner gloria
lee were arrested
police say they tracked down bills in
indiana
we're very lucky that this was not a
different case we were talking about 27
dead dogs
and but for the state of the art
surveillance system
and sprinkler system those dogs
absolutely would have perished
in that fire lee received five to 14
years in prison for arson
insurance fraud and attempted animal
cruelty
bills was sentenced to four to ten years
in prison and according to the
department of corrections
he was released in 2018. then in march
of
2020 police say bills opened fire both
in las vegas and
henderson in one instance in front of
children
this time police say they tracked down
bills in minnesota
one alleged victim testified in front of
the grand jury
he and bills don't like each other and
bills shot him in the legs and the back
of the head
he said he lost an eye in the shooting
and now suffers every day as a result of
those injuries
now bills is out of custody again on the
latest charges bill's posted
bond and is on house arrest with
electronic monitoring
a judge recently granted him permission
to travel to
illinois to visit his teen son who was
in a car crash
bills now faces 58 charges including
attempted murder
vanessa murphy 8 news now kirk bill's
defense team filed a motion to remove
prosecutor nicole canizzaro from the
case considering her position
in the nevada state legislate